I don't have a chain but I want one III
wore one on stage my buddy Kevin Matt
gave me a chain he goes where my chain
when I was in Brad I go what
cuz wear this I put it on and I looked
sexy and I had it I've never performed
with a chain on and in my cell mine was
it just a small chain with a little like
like a Saint Catherine thing on it like
a little way yeah and I was like
tasteful chain now now Kevin if you know
Kevin Mac you don't know I'm right tall
65 handsome son of a [ __ ] come rides a
Harley sponsor I think by India and
whatever the [ __ ] but a stud that looks
good on him easily certain guy handsome
guy guys when you're when you look like
him I put it on at your age and at my
age but I was like and in my sick mind I
was like this might weigh me down a
little on solid state I was like this is
not my neck well then I don't come right
but I've changed right before a show I'm
like I don't feel that comfortable I'm
be super self-conscious about it yeah
I'll run run and change yes sometimes my
shirt will be too tight because I shrunk
it as usual yeah or it's too little too
short and when I lift my arms up you can
see my that's not a little midriff yeah
you sure - short sure it's there my man
I want to bring back the baby shirt I
want to cut it right right belligerent
tit long game where than the NFL anymore
Maryland guys like you know why just gay
so nice but you go through periods time
when you feel like it's over and you're
irrelevant so I told the hole in the
most hilarious we say not entertained
not being able to get a movie made he
couldn't get the rocky whatever it was
made and and he [ __ ] was like sitting
at the bar and he's like well it's over
I had my run it's over I mean but dude
but still they still indie movie doesn't
matter you still like I had my run it's
a form of death and then his friend came
out is how you do anything I'm not doing
what not good does he want to make that
yeah and then this this this producer
said I read that script and made my wife
cry so anything like that I'm gonna yeah
I'm gonna I'm doing the movie but like
you know you always think that it's the
last time you I've never met an actor or
any or a director didn't didn't feel
like this was their last gig that
doesn't have done yes yeah you know
everybody ever I think being insecure
and insecure is is probably crucial I
don't mean sure do you know anyone who's
not I don't know it you know anyone
who's not know I don't
name the one we should talk about this
only because you and I are around
successful people and there a lot of
people who are younger listening John
there's play when I was Imus when I when
I was your age when I when I was when I
was in my 20s I thought people who were
up there were secure look I thought that
they had it all and they they had to
have the same but there's no such thing
no right like part of what drives you is
the fact that you always feel like
you're less than that's certainly for me
I don't know where I'd be if I didn't
hate myself a little bit so it's okay if
you don't like yourself what matters is
just take the actions and keep reaching
you're never gonna be self perfected but
at least you'll get harder we heard this
everywhere in the news yeah the problem
is well what to brother was the one yeah
so that's the problem but he wasn't
warmer his brother hired this guy hired
this guy New York medical examiner so he
was more Pro like conspiracy theory it's
more consistent with a homicidal
strangling than it is a suicidal you
know hanging that's what he was saying
whatever that means and yeah and then so
that wasn't really the news cuz that's
everywhere right now but then this guy
who was a dog expert was on Fox dog
expert yeah cuz you know that one dog
that was important in the killing that
Isis leader guy yeah yeah it was like
Malinois or something yeah I think this
guy says hold up I thought this dog if
Burt was weighing in on the episode no
he just throws it in the very light and
he can't wait so thank you and thank
nero for your service i appreciate it
absolutely if i could I throw a PSA out
real quick real quick just the the
remarkable nature of these dogs and them
being highlighted in the news creates a
huge - and by people that frankly
shouldn't have them if if you see the
the coverage and you decide I want one
of these dogs either by a Finnish
trained you know fully trained and
Finnish dog from a professional now or
just just don't get one at all and
Epstein didn't kill himself
hey guys so that was great you didn't
know what to do it is all okay wow
that's great
good night guys in the military said
that he's an expert dog trainer oh he's
an expert that's so funny awesome way to
go viral mode that's how he's right
about those dogs don't very very true
yes those those dogs like that every
trainer I know about our boy Nick West
is that his name he said he goes don't
get one of those dogs because you don't
get a high drive dog you had there the
problem is that they're [ __ ] is like
having a race car yeah they will bite
more so than a race car they will bite
somebody's leg in a spaceship yeah that
was you know like somebody that comes in
the wrong way yeah I'd be four you say
the wrong word if you have to have that
dog with you 24/7 and you have to trust
your boy yeah
it's a [ __ ] it's a it's a [ __ ]
it's chaos this cast
yes those dogs are not there's serious
animals they're called it's what they
call sharp dogs they're smart as [ __ ] I
also put a leash on a crocodile yeah
they'll bite a [ __ ] I had a crocodile
cover my buddy had one he was SWAT
sergeant and a kid comes in with his
friend and the dog was oh he was a
shepherd and he goes you afraid of dogs
and the kid goes yeah he's looking at
this wolf he goes he senses that don't
act weird that what'd he do there though
what the [ __ ] he's trusted you do the
dog is a [ __ ] wolf and it's looking
at me
there there it's a liability yeah I love
him but it's a liability yeah yet
another you gotten out of hand you gotta
be a you gotta be a veteran get a fully
finished dog and know that you have to
keep that [ __ ] kenneled if you're away
because if somebody comes in your house
they're getting bit they are amazing
dogs though yeah they're cool they're
incredible but they're not for they're
for professionals great I don't want to
see a bunch of civilians breed these
dogs now and have those dogs and then
it's just ridiculous they're too smart
to be neglect at all that's it
for realz Brian be responsible no good
cat came at that chicken sandwich I'm on
I feel like I'm a hot ones right now
real quick you're white
so when cat goes hey [ __ ] how spicy you
want your chicken sandwich we want it
white hot cat mean yeah caucasian long
time for me in the audience
mommy nut I saw a single tear I know I
am I to medium I feel so sick I've been
fasting all day that was a bad idea I
mean I feel like you put hot coals in my
mouth I'm dying right but why the left I
just crying
there's your feminine that's my profile
okay is there even hotter than the hot
yeah there is extra hot and then howling
chin would you get
I got medium what do I have you have hot
medium to your medium high medium hot
but mine's medium but I want to enjoy I
don't want like like behinds doing right
now
well show you at the Thai hot Tommy Cod
or whatever my poor out and how what
should have got howling I'll get you
guys not going in it's going in my
[ __ ] but you know different peppers
have different effects for me jalapenos
are the worst this is so weird to me I
thought a lot about this the amount of
time I spend at 52 doing jujitsu well
just well just recently but but I doing
this like I'm I just came from Higa
Machado's school I'm practicing arm bar
and I'm practicing guillotine it's very
relaxing to me because I feel like ah
good rounding off those edges in case
there's a situation at least I can at
least I'm not an idiot
it's been a long time since I've
grappled and I now check that off I'm
grappling again in boxing so these are
things I this sounds crazy you don't say
for are you enjoy doing I do love the
arm maybe you felt unsafe of course I
did it was moved to dish it eternal
world and you always get bullied
I didn't hear he said what you say dude
I can't say anything I didn't say that
wrong
I'm beat out like a frog and you said
that you were bill like the WB frog I
don't know what is this dude well I'm
saying I don't like the way you're
[ __ ] - no don't
get your finger out don't touch my
finger don't invade my personal you be
frog listen I have good genetic you do I
looked at Brennan we went to one of his
party so I was like well this is Snoop
Dogg video it was so crazy I went pants
see ya I was like I was like hey what
words when do we take the sex break
because this is an old big boy sir Krunk
in a car after a DMT session as you know
the DMT I couldn't figure out why I was
crying like that for Tim Kenny I love
Tim loved one my favorite people on
earth but he didn't want him to double I
was crying I was I didn't want him to
die and go back to war I'm talking about
I'm talking to my wife at the time he's
dude I've ever heard ass I've ever cried
I think behind his and then I couldn't
figure out like why am i crying I've
never the beard was in the back seat I
was like Evan let's go back in there I
walked in here
he was the dmt I forgot we did DMT gonna
be a little late he's got allergies he's
crying oh I was I mean dude that was you
trying to tell me a good cry feels nice
it does feel no you had a great
experience man I remember you just
laughing when that when that when that
chrysanthemum of divine light just
transcended and poured through the top
of your head and you just started paint
you just started laughing cuz it's so
beautiful that there's no other response
that actually makes there's nothing so
hard man like dude what do you think of
Adam laughs like the joke the same thing
a man DMT pens I think I was a little
skeptical so like people shouldn't be
doing these out in public and I still
believe that but if you do the DMT pens
in the same type of ceremony that we did
it is the [ __ ] way to go because for
one it's not going to burn your lungs
for two if you're actually in control of
your own pen you can reach the level of
DMT load that you want and then you can
keep sipping on the pen and stay there
oh so it feels like you're getting
contact with what I call what they call
the doctor see toes with little doctors
right these little doctors of light that
are like mint like fixing you it feels
like they're fixing you or they're
teaching you or they're talking to you
about something or showing you something
but with DMT normally it goes in this
curve and then it just slips away slips
away so fast but if you have the pen you
just keep sipping the pen it also felt
like up in the pen you can stay there
where do I get that pen yeah where were
you these
yeah but I also felt like I felt like I
was there for a while and that's how
long was that you're like that was like
a minute yeah but it felt like I was in
this gold heaven and like floating it is
the greatest thing I've ever done Texas
it's really [ __ ] special oh no I did
the MT and I came out gay yeah I don't
know is weird man give that to you as
it's a get sag if it's a gift